quelle est la question voici la réponse
yannick noah yannick noah là ni gloire
yannick noah oui quel est le nouvel
ambassadeur de la halle aux chaussures
sarenza nom qui qui est déçu de ne pas
entendre les sportifs blancs bon alors
c'est yannick toi alors quelles
personnalités se sont gênés face au
silence des sportifs blancs sur les
questions raciales alors c'est la
déclaration qu'il a fait le qui fait le
plus parler en ce moment ça concerne
yannick noah il s'est fait défoncer
yannick voilà je le dis rien sur les
réseaux sociaux il était chez laurent
delahousse hier soir et c'est vrai que
ça n'a pas été facile après pour yannick
noah après cette déclaration et nous
dire ce que vous en pensez
si vous êtes d'accord voilà deux avec ce
que dit yannick ou si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord
regardez ça fait du bien d'entendre
aujourd'hui qu'il y avait ma p tsonga
monfils no à prendre la parole peut-être
que pour beaucoup de jeunes ces
importantes vous entendre dire les
choses aussi et pour la parole afin que
les jeunes s'en occupe mais moi ce qui
me gêne ce sont tous des métis ou des
noirs pourquoi c'est une injustice qui
qui parle qui devrait parler est en tout
cas sensibiliser tout le monde c'est ça
qui ont vu les deux autres sportifs par
exemple blanc s'ils peuvent s'engager
dire les choses
oui parce que leur silence me chaîne
cela plus loin que ça ouais alors qu'est
ce que vous en pensez parce qu'après
yannick noah 2,5 yannick d'ailleurs qui
d'ailleurs faudra qu'on joue ensemble
très vite une technicienne yannick a
pris ces faits il s'est fait fracasser
sur les réseaux sociaux
voilà par plein de gens qu'est ce que
vous en pensez est ce que vous êtes
d'accord et qu'il doit ou raymond moi
j'ai du mal à être d'accord avec lui
parce que le racisme et des piles et des
deux côtés il n'est pas qu'il ya du
racisme contre les noirs il ya du
racisme aussi contre les blancs c'est du
deux côtés et c'est toujours après a
tout mélangé et mais là où je peux
comprendre yannick noah qui est
passionné de football
peut-être qu'il a fait un petit amalgame
dans les matchs de foot c'est vrai que
parfois il ya du racisme et les mecs ils
sortent pas du terrain et ça m'a
toujours choqué quand y'a un black qui
se fait chambrer dans un stade de foot
de radars ac c'est plus que le chanteur
était jugée en bref ce que j'ai pas
trouvé le bien sûr qui se fait traiter
de racisme eh ben les blancs ne sortent
pas les joueurs de foot ne sortent pas
si on laisse comme ça moi si c'était moi
je rejoins la ssii a que ça sur cette
partie là où je rejoins yannick noah je
serais sorti
c'est vrai que parfois les blancs ne
bouge pas quand il ya des propos
racistes dans les stades de foot
peut-être qu'il a fait cette âme alors
il ya beaucoup de gens il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ont répondu à yannick noah qui
avait énormément de sportif mais si on
fait plein de d'action mine de rien
après le drame qui s'est passé et qu' il
n'avait pas dû voilà bien suivre les
informations qu'ont dit les gens en
général oui mais voilà je comprends ce
qu'il a voulu dire et là où il a raison
c'est que ce n'est pas un puisque la
discrimination le racisme pour les
personnes noires etc
c'est pas un problème de noir c'est un
problème de d'humanité sur un problème
voilà c'est parce qu'on lui a reproché
sans comprendre ce que non mais ça tout
le monde a compris ce que voulait dire
yannick noah avait la grippe
le seul truc que les gens lui pro
proches sur les réseaux c'est de ne pas
avoir suivi mines d'oreilles de donner
une fausse information puisqu'ils disent
qu'il ya plein de sports qui là-bas au
web ils se sont insurgés qui ont fait
des voix les autres ce qui s'était passé
mais qu'est donc dans tous les cas que
ce soit vrai ou faux et en plus là en
l'occurrence c'est faux mais que ce soit
vrai ou faux ce qu'il dit depuis quand
aux juges ce que les gens fument ou sur
internet
est ce que les gens font dans les médias
on connaît pas la vie des gens nous dire
que si le mec il s'est pas déclaré en
tant que héros sur internet à dire des
phrases donner des discours c'est à dire
qu'il paie pas d action n'avait pas dire
qu'il fait pas d'attendre
arrêtez de juger les gens sur les
réseaux twitter c'est pas la vie alors
donnez pas la vie que je sais ce qui
vole bien hic c'est que parce qu'il y
avait peut-être des porte-voix et des
prises de position qui pouvait faire
avancer la cause et c'est ça qui voit là
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de
sportifs médias voilà les choses en
interne vous savez les mignons que
certaines personnes dame n'y a pas déjà
utilisé c'était bien beaucoup et la voix
pour voilà pour faire avancer la cause
louis even changement de date est ce que
viennent vraiment est ce que valérie est
ce que vient bien de quoi voulez juste
quand vous l'avez la maladie mais moi ce
que j'aime pas annoncé cette espèce
c'est déjà le début du fascisme de dire
moi je veux que intel ils réagissent et
zohra réalise comme ça c'est que cette
façon de montrer du doigt les médias
suscitent une n'agit pas si tu ne réagis
pas officiellement sur la gauche anti
noir c'est génial pour moi mais
l'horreur penser et de dire comme ça il
ya des gens qui sont discrets qui ne se
sentent pas de parler en public et ça
peut pas dire pour autant qu'ils
comptent pas les actes racistes
est ce que cette façon de juger voilà
mais c'est vrai que deux vraies normale
après la tombe on en entend aussi
beaucoup de gens dire votre silence
c'est comme une acceptation pas qu'il
faut
disait pas c'est parce qu'on est les
réseaux valérie eux non mais on nous
trompe et oui gilles moi j'aime pas
quand il donne des leçons
d'autant que par exemple son fils est
basketteur ya plein de basketteur
français blancs ils sont montés au
créneau les actes au moment où tu es
arrivé il avait qu'à lire ça il le
savait très bien ouais j'ai l'impression
qu'il a voulu un polar accros des oui
non mais je comprends sa sensibilité
yannick noah c'est vrai que c'est un
être sensible et on entend enfin le
propos pitié faites exactement oui c'est
vrai que c'était c'est ça qu'il faut pas
s'accrocher au lieu de rassembler sa
division battus sur un ton souffle et
raymond non c'est ça que je trouve
dangereux dans le climat on est sorti du
coronavirus on a dit qu'on fera plus
coronavirus on va tous se retrouvera sur
serait on veut assez d'accord horaire va
être des hommes bon on va faire
attention à l'autre
ca va encore pires exactions on avait je
suis d'accord c'est encore thierry
d'accord voix sur un star on va encore
message privé
on m'envoie regarde un noir qui s'est
fait tabasser dans la rue par des blancs
après j'ai des blancs des comptes de
gens blancs qui m'envoient des blancs
tabassé par des racailles regarde ce
qu'ils font des racailles
après j'ai une black qui m'envoient il
ne détient sur nos racailles non mais
c'est vrai on verra mais c'est ce que
c'est ce que les gens mondial et bon
après j'ai une blague qui m'envoie une
vidéo en me disant regarde faut
exterminer tous les rebeus et tous les
africains tous les tunisiens tous les
marocains faut que l'afrique devienne
noire c'est un bordel je comprends plus
rien vous voulez tous en fait tout le
monde est divisé
mais ça ça fait ça c'est dangereux ça
c'est super mais c'est vrai on n'a rien
d'un coronavirus qu'on va sortir on va
être bien on va tous on va faire l'armée
on va tous ensemble chacun on voit des
vidéos un blanc qui tape un noir un noir
assez loin des combats mais garde la
somme des propos malheureusement qui
divise alors qu'on a besoin d'unité en
sorte ou d'une grosse merde vue
d'accords et et terry pour chacun on a
perdu des cipan pire qu'avant c'est oui
car au pire qu'avoir comprends pas
pourquoi on cherche à diviser autant et
là il a plutôt divisé que réunissait